E CERTAINLY A VERY
GOOD RECORD IN THAT SENSE.
AND
MARCO SCANDELLA BACK TO WORK,
AND NOW -- THE SHOT AND THEY
W
IS ANTICIPATING, BUT YOU CAN SEE
THE DESPERATION ASD GOING TO
PLAY THE PUCHOUT HIS STICK.
HE LOST CONTROL!
AND THEN HE FAKES IT AND
THEY ARE, HUSSO BELIEVES THE
2-0 LEAD HERE IN GAME THREE IN
ST. LOUIS.T
THERE, AND THROWING KYROU WITH
RACE FOR THE PUCK, AND THE WILD
ZONE FOR ST. LOUIS, AND 20 AND
BLUES GET TO THE PUCK.
WINS IT TO ZUCCARELLA BACK TO
THE POINT, AND NOW SPURGEON LOBS
E AN
PERIOD MAKING SOME BIG STOPS FOR
THE WILD. S LIKE SOME EARLY
ONES.
>> Jim: I KNOW THAT WE WERE
GLUED TO THEP OF THE CIRCLES, A
GETS THERE, A CUCU
ZUCCARELLA WITH THE PUCK, AND HE
WAITS AND FIRES
T OF HIM. S SHOD
GREENWAY, AND HE IS COMING
THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE W.
THOMAS AROUND THE OTHER WAY, AND
KYROU QUICKLY IN FRONT, ANWOULDE
THROWN ON THE ICE.
>> Jody: WILD FLOWERS, RIGHT?
BUT O'REILLY GETS IT, AND SCOOTS
TO THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE, AND
THAM WATCHING DAVID PERRON AND
WILL AGE MYSELF HERE, BUT NO
MORE
LITTLE BIT AS TARASENKO, AND S
ICE, AND BOUNCING PUCK IN FRONT,
AN
SLOT, AND THE BENCH AFTER THE
US
YOU CAN SEE FAUL
BRODIN WITH TH